grateful to announce that we have some
new tour locations coming up Greenville
South Carolina November 8th at the Peace
Center Huntsville Alabama November 19th
at the Von Braun Center in Atlanta
Georgia November 29th and 30th at the
Fox Theater
tickets for these shows will be
available this Wednesday September 27th
at 10 A.M local time with the pre-sale
code Rat King General on sale begins
Friday November 29th at 10 A.M local
we also have some tickets left for
Washington D.C Las Vegas Norfolk VA
Roanoke VA and Huntington West Virginia
get all your tickets through theovan.com
t-o-u-r uh to avoid uh secondary sites
today's guest is a presidential
candidate for the 2024 U.S presidential
election he's an author he's an attorney
he's an environmentalist I'm grateful to
have him return to the podcast to
discuss his campaign and see what's
going on he's a dear friend and I'm
grateful for his time today's guest is
Robert Kennedy Jr
me
I'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks man yeah I feel pretty good I got
some vitamin D today I went for a run
you know I think I was feeling like
overwhelmed so sometimes when I feel
like
even if I feel anything too much it's
like I feel like if I do something in
motion it helps me you know and getting
some vitamin D helps me too yeah move a
muscle change of thought yeah
but I had the same experience yesterday
where I you know they had me scheduled
like back to back all day and I said I
just need to get I I and I I just
canceled one of my appointments and I
went out in the sun
for an hour and I just it was
transformative
yeah it's interesting I think we forget
that we're supposed to beat Plants like
that you know or that were part because
our humans part plants too do you think
no I know although the microbiome has a
lot of
plants and it's I guess it's part of our
body and it's a plant I suppose but
um we are definitely uh
or a zoonotic species rather than a
plant species dang
yeah sometimes I guess I feel like a
plant
um or I don't know if I sit by a window
I feel good you know if somebody comes
up and smells me if I smell good I feel
good I guess so that's kind of like a
flower maybe I don't know maybe I'm
losing my mind
um good to see you man you too yeah you
look great
you didn't you look amazing well I feel
pretty good man I'm just I've been
staying pretty busy I'm trying to think
of what's been going on have you been in
Nashville yeah I've been over there a
decent amount you know um I couldn't
believe how that is growing there yeah
there's like 20 cranes above that's the
thing they must have all the Crayons
from everywhere in the United States
there yeah it's been it's been busy I
mean even since I just moved there like
three years ago it's like I'll go down
streets now and everything's
everything's changing it's really nice
one of the things that I like best there
I have the best neighbors there my
neighbors are really nice
um and it still has a really small
it has a small town Vibe like you
couldn't cheat on your wife there that's
what I tell people
you could not do it I mean you could I
think a lot of people have tried but you
could it's just there's too much it
still has like that a little bit of that
southern gossip Vibe you know uh do you
have like like a a little house or yeah
I got me a little house in a
neighborhood it's pretty normal nothing
too fancy I mean it's a nice home but
um it's nothing like I don't have like a
uh water slide or anything you know or
anything like that or like a
um part of an ax yeah I don't know yeah
I don't know
um but it's been good man it's been a
nice change of pace I feel a little bit
more connected to just like regular
Society because I think in La it's like
a it's just a different Universe out
here than like regular cities or towns
in America for sure
um and there's so many people here you
know I think people start to feel a
little bit I don't want to say
Expendable but it's like some people you
know you're you're not going to see them
ever again so it there's like
a different amount of um value sometimes
to the interaction that you have to put
into it you know like in a smaller
Community you have to have you have to
create a level of probably more respect
for people and stuff and like um
whereas in a city you're just gonna does
that make any sense yeah I remember it
was as a writer for the New Yorker I'm
trying to remember his name but he's
kind of a philosopher
and he was talking about the um that
there's a formula actually that you know
people are rude and in big cities
because the chance of them ever running
into you again is is more remote whereas
if you live in a small town I've lived
in
Montgomery Alabama which is really a
small town and uh hayneville Alabama and
then I lived in Deadwood South Dakota uh
you know a couple of other small towns
in my life and everybody's nice and when
you're driving down the road and you're
pickup truck
everybody who has you on the road waves
their hand like that yeah
he was saying uh he was telling the
story that um
uh that Mother Teresa when she came to
New York
she tried to start one of her little you
know con monasteries to take care of the
poor in New York and that um they
eventually ended up closing it because
they didn't want to put an elevator in
the place and they said no we'll just
carry the sick people
up the stairs ourselves I love that idea
yeah but in New York the public health
agencies wouldn't let them do it so they
said okay we're leaving
a g at one point mayor Koch had a uh had
a heart attack mayor Koch yeah okay and
gosh was uh he was uh the mayor of New
York
for long long-term mayor and he had a
heart attack and he nearly died and she
went to visit him in his hospital bed
and what she thought was a great
kindness because you know she's
a Catholic and he's a Jewish mayor and
it just was a you know it was kind of a
spiritual act but when she was up there
she asked him can he give me a parking
place in front of my uh in front of my
building
and uh
as a joke no she wanted a parking place
but it kind of I saw his Mother Teresa
well of course you would give her a
parking place if you got on their issue
there he is with the Mother Teresa
that's hilarious
but she you know it's just the idea that
she had an angle you know once you go to
New York you always got to have an angle
yeah and maybe it is you're just like
and I always feel like La is kind of
like an air it always feels like the
whole city feels like a little bit like
an airport to me it's like I feel like I
never leave the airport here like it
just the whole it just it feels like
this thoroughfare of just people going
in and out you know yeah
um I sometimes I start to feel like
America starts to feel like that
sometimes I think it starts to feel to a
lot of people like
um it almost feels like a shell company
sometimes like a shopping mall yeah or
like it feels like an LLC for like big
bit it starts to sometimes feel like an
LLC for like big business yeah does that
make any sense that makes a lot of sense
I mean I think that's what it's becoming
and one of the things that like I I'm
talking about a lot now is is um you
know they it's a housing price I housing
prices yourself yeah you know what I was
um I tried the Monsanto case in San
Francisco
with a big team of attorneys and we
tried three cases in a row so we had
about 20 000 cases
and the way that you know this kind of
uh uh multi-state litigation and the
case was that they were it was poisonous
right yeah it was it was causing
Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma okay so we had
enough science to prove that it could
cause on it did a good cause on a
Hodgkin's lymphoma and then we had
we ended up having 50 000 people who had
gotten on the Hodgkin's lymphoma
and but the way that you try the case
you try them one at a time until if you
win three or four in a row then the
company says and Monsanto says okay now
we know what the value of the case so
the first case we got 289 million yeah I
just saw this brought that up wow the
second case we got
um and so that was one client and there
that was one that was uh Dwayne Johnson
who who's not the rock you're not
talking about him not the rock this was
African-American
school superintendent you know his job
was to spray the Weeds on the property
and keep the mow the lawn and do that on
a school public school
and he was he had a backpack on a
sprayer and it leaked all the time and
he began getting lesions on his back and
he called up Monsanto he called him
three times and said could this be from
uh because it says safe as Asbury
nothing could happen to you and it has
pictures it had pictures on the label of
people spraying their weeds wearing like
Bermuda shorts and a Hawaiian shirt so
it was implying that you don't have to
take any protection with this stuff
because it's so safe wow oh he thought
he felt like it was coming from that
from the and it turned out to be not
lymphoma
it was precancerous lesions and but they
would never return his phone call and
they knew it and they just didn't want
to you know so they they uh they
sandbagged them
and he um and and he he was the sweetest
guy when we got him on the stand he was
married to this beautiful uh Hispanic
woman they had fallen in love the first
time they saw each other at Community
College and they had this wonderful
marriage
and he couldn't sleep in the bed with
her anymore because
he had so many lesions on his body and
you know he wouldn't go in the swimming
pool because he you know if anybody saw
him in the pool they would think they
were going to get a disease so his life
was it was just so miserable and
the jury loved him that gave him 280
million 289 million and then the next
one I forgot we got I I think we got
around 300 million the second the third
one we asked for it was a couple
who were both gardeners home gardeners
and they brought their dog with them
they had a Labrador retriever the
labrador died on hydrogen diphoma what
he got at the same time they did the
couple both gone to the same Retreat and
the dog got it the dog died first and
then
um the uh you know then they were they
were really sick
we asked the jury for a billion dollar
and we had a big argument about it you
know what do you ask Jerry because you
don't want to ask them for too much
because then they think you're
overreaching and they may punish you
okay uh the one guy was arguing doing
the closing argument a lawyer called
Brent Wisner very young lawyer um but
really brilliant and he uh and we were
all saying you should ask them for 300
million that's what the other juries
were paying us
and he said I'm going to ask him for a
billion I feel like the jury likes us
they came back with 2.2 billion but we
asked him for a billion yeah and uh so
they were pissed him on Santa they were
so angry because we also showed that
that's the lawyer right there I would
just walk by Brent listener wow
um God I got to pick up some Monsanto on
the way home yeah you got to go to law
school too yeah one or the other man
yeah I got to get a case like this but
anyway I I didn't mean to go off on this
but what I was saying is
when we were trying these cases we were
trying one after the other so I ended up
spending like the better part of a year
in San Francisco and every morning when
I was in San Francisco before court I
would go down to the courthouse to the
uh to the gym
in Union Square
Union Square is the center of San
Francisco and it's the center of
Commerce it has all the big uh um you
know American iconic American stores
like uh Macy's and Bloomingdale's and uh
Nordstrom and GAP and the Old Navy and
Levi and then it has all the foreign
stores like Prada and Dela Valley and
odd Gucci and Ferragamo and Hermes yeah
Ferragamo and uh Burberry and all of
those so it's like Fifth Avenue is the
Fifth Avenue and people come from Asia
all over to do their shopping there
so you know I went back three weeks ago
and it was astonishing those houses are
or those stores are all boarded up
they're every one of them is closed wow
and
they're closed because all of them
homeless on the street making the chaos
that's going on in the street in San
Francisco makes people feel unsafe yes
some guys instead of started a pop-up
bar do you see that a guy started a bar
where oh one was bar see if you can
bring that up okay
yep I got it
yeah look at this I mean I think you're
starting to see
yeah people are like well I'm so
homeless there's obviously no zoning
going on so why don't I open up a Dave
and Buster's type of Place Denver
homeless Camp features pop-up bar
um yeah it's wacky
let's see a Decked Out open there there
you go see look you can see the bottles
right there they have a kind of V I'm
going to call it VIP but I would call it
maybe h-i-v-i-p it looks a little dicey
over there sorry and I should have said
that man but yeah but you know it's it's
a lot of people have been ill and
um but yeah this is I mean I think
people are going to start starting
businesses you know
I don't know that could be the pop-up
Speakeasy which features lounge chairs
umbrellas and astro turf has taken over
the sidewalk at 23rd and champ uh Champa
streets which the city's growing
homeless population has turned into an
encampment I love this kind of stuff so
um so I we're hearing there was an open
bar that's where the Denver Police
Patrol Division Chief said
um anyway yeah I think but at least it's
evolving it's not just
homeless people just being homeless at
least I think you're going to start to
see mom and pop businesses out there you
know here's what you know my son
actually because I I had a lot of um I
have a lot of assumptions about why
people are homeless
and it it's you know there's 525 000
homeless people in this country
and but
50 of the unsheltered homeless are in
California
okay but California only has 12 percent
of the population but it's 50 percent of
the of the unsheltered homeless and
unsheltered homeless means homeless that
don't have a place to sleep yeah it's
okay it's people who are you know on the
sidewalks like freelance yeah right or
they're in shelter you know they're yeah
like free range yeah
so
um here's my assumptions that
homelessness is linked to drug addiction
it's linked to mental illness
um it's linked to you know poverty
and that people are in one of the
reasons there's somebody homeless in
California is that everybody knows that
San Francisco
as this very generous kind of giving
attitude towards social services and so
if you're homeless anywhere else in the
country you you know you you'd like to
move the good weather yeah you know you
don't want to be in New York sleeping on
a great in the middle of winter when
it's snowing
get on a Greyhound and come out to San
Francisco and you know
um and
celebrate yeah and I also had heard this
which turns out not to be true that that
in some cities like Dallas
or Nashville if you are homeless at a uh
instead of putting you in jail
they give you a bus ticket to San
Francisco oh wow so I don't know if it's
true or not anyway somebody's son
turned me on to this writer called my
son Connor and who you know
Matthew Desmond and Matthew Desmond has
written these books on homelessness and
he's done these studies on homelessness
and what and they in in San Francisco
they actually went around and
interviewed thousands and thousands of
office people
and what they found is
that um
that the people who are homeless in San
Francisco are from San Francisco and
they're from California and they weren't
they didn't come from somewhere so it's
not a lot of people yeah Boston or
transplants or whatever right
he also says that
it it has it it has very little to do
with drug addiction that you know the
states like West Virginia
as much more drug addiction than San
Francisco and yet it doesn't have a
homeless problems West Virginia has much
worse poverty problem than San Francisco
San Francisco actually I think it's the
richest city in the country it may be
wrong but I think it's the riches and
um and it doesn't so
and in terms of mental illness you have
to assume they're the same yeah you know
there's a reason but but also Detroit
Detroit has much higher drug addiction
much higher poverty and it doesn't have
a homeless problem
and what Matthew Desmond says is the
reason for almost one reason one reason
is housing prices it all has to do with
with housing prices in California you
know we have the highest housing prices
in the country
um here in La Where We Are
the average home cost eight hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars which means you
have to earn 250 000 to be able to pay
to be able to pay for that and why do
they get so high like is it demand that
makes them so high I'm going to tell you
this the average home in our country
two years ago was two hundred and
fifteen thousand
the today is 400 000. and the interest
rates have gone from three to seven
percent so kids today like your kids and
my kids are never going to buy a home
you know it used to be but if so if
they're not going to buy a home yeah and
the median price of home sold by
Realtors is risen sharply since the
beginning of the pan yeah and and here's
why this is happening
if there's three big companies BlackRock
State Street yeah these the biggest
companies you know and they have a
monopoly on a lot of the housing market
right well what they do they own
everything okay including they on each
other so it's really just one big
company and and BlackRock that it has 10
trillion dollars under management
the GDP of California is three or ten
trillion the GDP of California is three
trillion dollars
and so they're three times the size of
California California economy is the
fifth largest in the world of all
Nations so when you have that much
control can't you just make your own
universe
so they own
those three companies own 88 of the s p
500. so they basically just own
everything and now what they've decided
is they want to own every single family
home in our country so they're that and
and they're now on track there's now on
trajectory if we continue it on this
trajectory they will own the
corporations
will own 60 of the uh single family
homes in our country and they're you
know they they pay nothing for money so
they're like if you're the richest
person in the country
their blackrock's cost of money is 30
lower than you so you you know when so
they're competing against our kids and
your kids why is it so different they
want it now they want to own everything
so why is the percentage of the cost of
the value of of borrowing oh because
they are that their credit is so
impeccable oh I see they have like a
900. yeah so they they got the better
than the best credit rating I got 670 or
something I don't know what's okay I
don't know yeah but isn't that like
privatized communism or something that's
what it feels like oh yeah it's like
socialism for the rich and you know this
is barbaric merciless
ruthless Savage can you listen for the
poor yeah do you think it did some
trickle-down effect of that that makes
people feel like
yeah I don't know I mean I I was talking
we had this guy John vervacion and he
talks a lot about meaning and stuff like
that you know and he said that people
feeling like they're part of a country
or they're they have like a part of a
home you know part of a group it it
creates a lot of meaning for them you
know just in their life yeah and I think
I noticed even with my own like probably
like our parents and stuff I think a lot
of them were very like pro-america and
like you know they had family members
that died for our country and they you
know it meant something to them to be
part of America and then now I think a
lot of them see this kind of unfolding
or like kind of the flag kind of like
fraying at the stitching you know and I
think it's very scary because if you
don't if you start to feel like you
don't have your country
then I think then you start to feel like
okay it's every man for himself in a way
does that make any sense yeah and you
know
and you're absolutely right there's a
poll that came out three weeks ago that
showed that in 2013
kids between 18 and 35 years old that 85
of Young Americans
um said they were proud of the United
States and then another poll that Saint
Paul came out three weeks ago that
showed that only 17 percent of kids say
that they're proud to be and I said
really you know devastating but one of
the things that you are saying I think
is true that
if you own a home
you care more about your community you
care about the schools you know you care
about the police oh that's a great point
the hospitals you take care of your
garden you know you make it look nice
you might be more likely to help your
neighbor exactly because you're there
you're part of the community
and turning us all into you know and you
it you also are a participant in the
capitalist system because
if you own a home you have Equity yeah
which means let's say you want to start
a business even like a tiny business
like buying you know buying a sewing
machine yeah doing sewing what else can
we do you can do or you know if you want
to start at restaurants popcorn like a
caramel corn exactly something like that
yeah thanks and um but you could get a
loan you can get alone right on your
house and so you you have an entree and
a capitalist system yeah and you make it
because then you're always pop
everything's possible you could sit down
with your family at night and be like
hey Mom and Dad are thinking about doing
this business what do you guys think and
maybe your son's proud of you and it
creates excitement in your house you
know and even if like I remember my mom
went to law school and she couldn't do
it because she had too many kids and it
was too much work but I was still always
proud of her that she tried to do it you
know like I think yeah having the the
financial ability to do stuff like that
is just so important man and then
otherwise you feel yeah if you're just a
renter if everybody's a renter you don't
nobody you just feel like you're like a
renter by force like you don't even have
a choice to be a renter you know yeah
um yeah that's kind of scary how do we
battle against that and is it something
that a president can do or a political
official can do or it's something that
how do you how do we turn reverse that
um well I don't know I mean there
there's parts of their
um of of what they're doing that yeah a
president can do it for example they own
all the packing companies so there's
only four meat packing companies and and
those companies have a Stranglehold on
farmers and consumers
and they should have been prosecuted a
long time ago for antitrust but because
BlackRock is so powerful nobody will
touch them wow and so that's a dark arts
huh yeah I mean they're just you know
what they're doing is they're just
they're just strip mining the wealth and
Equity from the American middle class
and you see that you know um yeah it's
sad and how do we how do who is it who
is Blackrock
the head of it is uh as the CEO as I
call Larry Fink
he's also on the board of directors of
the world economic Forum so in the world
economic Forum you know is meets in to
have a it's a billionaires Boys Club
a meeting to have us every year and they
try to figure out what
um their plans are for the rest of
humanity are they greedy I would say
they're they're they they have a bad
reputation for a very self-serving
policies their big policy is called the
Great reset
and what here's Cloud Schwab says
famously he says under the great reset
you will have not you will own nothing
but you will be happy
so that's what that's what they believe
yeah so they do have a belief their
belief is that you will own nothing but
you'll be happy all of us will own
nothing but they will work because they
will own everything
and they may be a little happier who
knows wow today's episode is brought to
you by betterhelp
if you um if you need therapy or you've
considered therapy it's
it's okay to try it out I've tried so
many therapists
you know it takes you a while sometimes
to find the right one but when you do
it's a good fit and it feels good
better help can help that's right it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge
take a break from your thoughts if
they're bothering you with better help
visit betterhelp.com Theo today to get
10 off your first month that's better h
e l p
betterhelp.com
Theo this episode is sponsored by
betterhelp the weather is getting cooler
and that means it's time to bundle up
get you some stockings on I got look at
that legging get you a legging on Daddy
or Mama legging up
get you a hat scarf whatever
ibada they can help you do it
that's right ibada gives you cash back
on winter coats hats gloves scarves
anything actually groceries produce
Personal Care Pantry Goods just download
the ibada app
the average e-body user earns 100 per
year
that could cover the cost of of a
shopping trip new school supplies a
Thanksgiving turkey get that big bird
other apps give you points that don't
amount to much with the body you get
real cash back that you can cash out to
your bank account PayPal or gift cards
just download the Ibotta app now and use
code Theo to start earning real cash
back
just go to the app store or Google Play
Store and download the free Ibotta app
that's i b o t t a and use code Theo
that's Ibotta
ib-o-t-t-a in the Google Play or App
Store and use code Theo start getting
cash back today
so how do we stay positive how do you
what do you do to stay positive when
things like this come into your brain
because I think a lot of people it it uh
I mean this is why you have people that
start to go to conspiracy theories this
is why you have people that start to
look like oh for alternate people are
looking for Hope really a lot of times
in a conspiracy theory people are also
looking for hope they're looking for
something that shows them that something
that's out of what Everything feels like
could be possible right
um do you uh well do you let me ask you
this
do you consider yourself a conspiracy
theorist no
but I consider myself open to curiosity
you know
um I think
yeah I consider myself open to curiosity
I think it'd be silly not to listen to
possibility
and I think some of the it's sometimes
it's the Curious guy who at first people
are like this guy's bought bananas who
ends up being
Bananas Foster you know which is good if
you've had it or not yeah I haven't yeah
it's pretty good I'll say that dude one
of my I used to work at this at this
restaurant and one of my co-workers he's
like man I hate seeing Bananas Foster on
the menu because I was raised in a
foster home and it makes me sad not
ridiculous
well yeah like just to equate Like
Bananas Foster and being raised in a
foster home but I was like but I bet he
still had some every now and then I
think it made him feel pretty good but
um but yeah I think would you ask me
about it oh it is I was just asking
about conspiracy theory yeah I don't
think well I think since to me since the
new like the news started to get
compromised it feels like a few years
ago and I'll one thing I do like using
is that word compromise that's kind of
like a conspiracy there is a word you
know but I feel like when I was when I
was a child it felt like the news was
real and it and it was like this is the
news and it was honest I don't know if
it was that could have been me Romancing
it too but it felt like that and then at
a certain point which feels like about
maybe 10 years ago the news started to
become more yeah different did you
notice that in your life
yeah I did it on I watched it happen
because
originally the like the the news
um you know they they going back to when
they invented radio in 1928
they passed a law that was called the
fairness document was called you know
Community Communications act and they
said
um you that all
they did a bunch of things they said
nobody could monopolize the news so now
there's five companies that on all the
TV all the radio all the newspapers and
most the internet content providers
and they didn't want that to happen
because they thought then you know these
large corporations will control what
we're thinking because they're going to
control the information flow and that's
bad for democracy they said you you know
you can own no more than eight radio
stations and you couldn't own a
newspaper and a radio station or
television station the same that sounds
like a good choice that sounds like very
that seems fair to me yeah they wanted
it for the quality of ownership it was
called the fairness Doctrine but they
also said
if you if you if you're using the public
Airwaves which means radio or television
that if you make a statement you need to
give the other side a chance to respond
and you also need to put the news on
every day at times when Americans are
likely to be at home to say it so they
have that in order to
oh like NBC did not own that airwave it
all it had a license to use it and it
could only use it if it benefited the
public interest
the way that it did that is it said okay
you're going to create a news division
the news divisions were always lost
money but they were willing to pour
money in because it was the only way
they could hold on to their license and
they made a guy
wait explain that part to me sorry um
that's right see what they can say is
you can you can use a uh the airwave to
make money by entertaining people right
but you have to tell the real news the
authentic news the important news that
affects policy decisions that Americans
have to make about their government okay
and you have to do it every day at a
time when all Americans are going to be
home are likely to be home so that's why
we had a six o'clock news hour it's also
radio stations if you probably I don't
know if you remember this or not but it
used to be even the top 40 music
stations
had a news break like every 15 minutes
there was a short in his break when they
would tell you the nurse Hall Harvey
remember him exactly good day yeah
yeah exactly well they had to do that
that was a legal obligation
and the wow and the News divisions were
separate from the rest of the operations
and they were Untouchable so they'd
bring some you know really a credible
figure like Newton minnow or we had
Walter Cronkite and Huntley and Brinkley
and John Chester these guys
who were you know total Integrity people
and everybody the most incredible man
the most the most believed credible man
in America was Walter yeah and so and
all of those newscasters were people of
extraordinary integrity
then what happened is Ronald Reagan when
he ran for president in 1980 he had the
support of the uh big Studio heads in
California because he'd been the
California governor
they wanted to abolish the fairness
Doctrine so they could get their hands
it was like it's consolidate the entire
media in under Monopoly control and he
had the Christian right
and the Christian broadcasting stations
did not want to do you know the fairness
they didn't want to show the other side
because they didn't want to show Satan's
side of the argument right so they all
wanted to get rid of the fairness
Doctrine
and So Reagan came in and uh and
appointed a guy I think his name was Tom
wheeler to run
um
the FCC the Federal Communication and
they threw out the fairness document at
that point you saw this huge
consolidation where they started buying
up everything
you also saw the news divisions were
told okay
you know we don't we don't really need
you to have integrity anymore we need
you to make money so the news divisions
became profit centers and so you saw
more and more news that was not really
news it was you know about Brad and JLo
and it was entertainment yeah it was
tough to get eyeballs to make people and
violence and War and you know
um and so you saw this deterioration
where from a highly credible people on
the news to people that you have today
who are just you know propagandists for
the government and for the
pharmaceutical companies Muppets man
yeah the people people are turned into
Muppets did um but so
so whenever they so the CR it was
Christian activism that made them end up
making them repeal that it was a
combination of things the great the
Christian broadcasters
for good reason you know they had good
reason they didn't want to tell because
like for example yeah give me an example
I'll give you an example of that that
um NBC I think it was either NBC or ABC
he was having advertisements we're
selling advertisements for Mustang which
is the automobile oh yeah that Stang
Abby at that point it was the biggest
gas guzzling automobile and so the the
uh an asthma Society of America they
hated Mustangs yeah they didn't like
Mustangs because come on dude you have
asthma if you get a Mustang you got a
chance with the ladies I feel like but
if you just show up with asthma dude
yeah yeah it's not a good seller yeah it
has has one speed dude
you know sorry go on
so they they wanted to do an ad saying
Mustangs are bad because they're making
us you know they're making us have
asthma attacks
and the and the network didn't want to
do it they said no you know because they
right we want to sell Mustangs we want
to sell Mustangs
so they they told the the asthma Society
you can't you know we're not gonna let
you we're not going to sell you ad space
so they soon they went to the Supreme
Court Supreme Court said you gotta you
gotta allow them to stop both sides
and they upheld the fairness Doctrine so
you if you applied that Christian
broadcasting and said you got you're
using a public airwave right you know if
there's atheists out there who want to
give their side of the story right maybe
you'll have to do that so they didn't
want to wow they didn't want to do that
so they were uh you know you can see the
rationale yeah and then also that leans
into more like towards yeah things being
able to create monopolies then it seems
like you know yeah well the Monopoly
exactly and now we are where we are
today what was your sad every city you
go to like I go to a city if you you go
as a comedian you go to do radio
sometimes before and you know uh it used
to be you had kind of a local radio
station and now all of them or most of
them are kind of Clear Channel you know
and I'm not denouncing Clear Channel I
don't but they're all like usually like
part of a bigger group you know and you
can't find like a local newspaper
anymore like that used to be like part
of the community like getting yourself
in the newspaper you would get like a
little trophy for it's not you know you
didn't do nothing really maybe you found
a missing person or something and they
would put you in the newspaper or
something you know but it was like you
kind of got to see like everything that
was going on in your community like
baseball scores for Little League games
I think things that made you feel
attached to your environment you know
and uh they don't have that anymore it's
like everything's just too big now to
get it to fit in like smaller
communities you know or maybe you'll get
a paper like once a week now or
something you know it's just different
no I you know I agree 100 sound like
that I think that's
you know and I think there's a real
appetite for local news people want to
know what the you know what happened in
the baseball I mean like you know I grew
up reading about you know kids who I was
playing you know sports with yeah right
and um and you'd read about them in the
local papers they were Heroes to you
yeah I would say you had Local Heroes
you know it's like yeah now it just
feels like they want all your Heroes to
be like from the Marvel universe or
you're not even allowed to have a hero
anymore you know
um and I don't know maybe I'm maybe I'm
Romancing that a little bit but I
definitely notice it when I go home I
can't find like the local news and see
kind of what's going on and then so
you're not attached to it you don't
really where do you you consider home
Nashville I'm from uh Louisiana from
Covington Louisiana
so but um this Covington is that is that
in the delta or something no Covington
is south of the dead it's kind of like
uh let me see south west of the uh Delta
yeah Covington is over there we had I'll
tell you something neat about Covington
well we have the tallest statue of
Ronald Reagan and you're welcome to come
see it whenever you want really yeah and
Michael Lane was supposed to come there
one time but he couldn't make it Michael
Landon he was supposed to stop in he
didn't make it though that's a big
selling point for the yeah Michael
Landon was almost here I guess it's a
pretty big look at that statue though
buddy oh I can't tell how big it is
bigger than the trees though yeah it's
10 feet tall or it could be somebody
said it's even 12 feet tall but I think
that somebody had a bad ruler on them
but
um also Lee Harvey Oswald went to our
Middle School there
uh for a little bit yeah and what else
um the Tulane primate facility is there
and they tested the uh polio vaccine
they actually made the polio vaccine
that ended up giving cancer to a lot of
women to like cervical cancer
it had a virus then a monkey virus and
it called sv40 yeah that's where they
tested it at yeah and some of the
monkeys got out when I was a kid and we
got to get out of YMCA summer camp top
and look for him which is pretty crazy
when you think about it is that true
yeah
they had a Kenny Rogers Roasters and
we're out there wrangling chimps with a
couple of local police
oh pretty cool huh
um but anyway there's actually you know
there's a book you go the Escape right
there
oh wow there's a book called Mary's
monkey yeah and it's about uh you know
the uh Dr Mary's monkey is that it
maybe it's just Mary's monkey doctor
Mary's monkey yeah Mary's monkey
and it's about the uh the secret life
it's about the Kennedy assassination but
it's about the two-lane lab and uh there
were people involved in that lab who
were you know who were involved with Lee
Harvey Oswald and did you go down a lot
of rabbit holes ever like kind of
searching like just about information
about you know I I feel like
assassinations and stuff I'm really
evidence-based
oh I don't make any presumptions but I I
read everything yeah but and if it's
that book is actually very very well
researched and very interesting yeah
yeah I think I don't know if I've read
all of it but I've definitely read a
decent amount of it
um
man yeah congratulations since I saw you
last you were running for
election yeah
that's cool man uh you didn't see that
coming yeah I don't know because I think
I almost think I asked you about it I'll
have to go back and see if there was a
clip where I asked you if you would at
some point
I didn't have any intention
um was it hard to did you have to
convince your family that it was okay
for you to run well the one one person I
had to convince was my wife my kids were
like uh
I actually went up to Boston and they I
had three boys who were in Boston at
that point
and I went out and took him out to lunch
and they were like
they weren't like okay go get them Dad
they were like okay this is what you you
know buy the ticket take the ride you
know and they they were not
um you know that I think now they're
much happier about it yeah because the
way it's kind of turned out
but they didn't know what was going to
happen at that point and then Cheryl
who you know
um uh
it took she took a lot of convincing but
what happened is I was you know I
thought at one point because they were
censoring me in fact you got you know
yeah we got sensors our episode got
taken down that's right and then
miraculously got put up again how did
that happen
like a month ago oh it came back up on
YouTube one of the episodes that have
been taken down came back up on YouTube
I mean it had been gone Bobby it had
been gone and then it just showed back
up
that's weird well you sit with them
and I doubt if that's the reason because
there's YouTube yeah they're still
taking our stuff down wow good for you
that's cool in your lawyer because then
you can sue somebody if you need to
that's a great idea you guys actually
made a wager whether or not that episode
would be taken down RFK uh he said it
would be and Theo bet him that it
wouldn't
oh dang how much is it for yeah how much
was that for we have the clip one sec
all right it's gonna get interesting
we'll see if anybody's getting paid this
week right here brother
God this could be bad well whatever it
is Bobby we'll donate to your campaign
okay
um how have campaign donations been oh
you have this you know we were Eric
Clapton concert last night let's play a
question that came in actually right
here from a guy uh for you Bobby that's
right is this live this is not live none
of this is live and this question isn't
live this is because I want to make sure
you have an option of not playing this
podcast video no I don't I think we're
okay
yeah I mean we you know I'm generally
curious and I think I'm worried about
your career oh thanks well the good I
feel like I own my own career until like
I don't need a Hollywood career you know
but it's definitely I worry about like
my career of like I guess maybe like
YouTube canceling us or people saying
that we can't do this anymore you know
yeah that's the scary part is this on
YouTube yeah this will be on YouTube
so with our last one state up
okay well let's make a bet
five bucks
inflation's happening a lot let's make
it 10. we were ahead of the curve big
question right here
but anyway last night you asked about
donations we got uh yeah we're at the
Eric Eric Clapton
and there's Steve Stills Eric Clapton
and we met and did that at a private
home in Brentwood and uh we got 2.2
million dollars in that way
um we're you know we're doing well on
donations
um how is it because you were kind of
like looked at as like a guy that was
like
a nut case by some people right yeah not
by me I thought you were definitely
curious and active you know and I knew
you as a person so I knew that like you
seem like a like as normal as a guy
could be to me you know were you
surprised when people started to get on
board though with you like because I
remember I listened to you I mean I I
listened to you on Rogan and I thought
it was one of his best episodes I
thought it was just I remember you
thanking him for letting him letting you
speak right and it was like you know I
remember this listing and I just got a
clear layout of exactly kind of where
you'd been and how you ended up where
you were you know
um and I thought it was just awesome and
I thought that was such a great
interview did things start to turn after
that or when did things kind of start to
turn do you feel like the big turn for
me was a podcast I did before that
called all in you know that podcast it's
David sacks and it's a bunch of
um tech people
uh who are you know leaders in the in
the kind of attack Bitcoin uh
uh Community or San Francisco based okay
David Friedberg okay
and it's very very popular I mean I I
cannot I I can't tell you how popular
the reason I know how popular it is is I
almost every day somebody comes up to me
and says I saw you on that wow no matter
where I am in the country and it's a
very weird demographic because it's not
it's all kinds of people like it'll be
like an old lady and you know young
college kids and
um that's amazing I'm not going to check
this out all in with shamok Jason sax
and friedberger Freiburg
[Music]
um
and so they you know I went on there and
there's four guys and they all kind of
grilled me yeah and uh and then you know
then
uh Rogan brought me on Megyn Kelly was
really good with me she she had me on
about three times when you know nobody
would let me on
and then Fox started letting me on a lot
and so I I could go on my you know the
thing is that my I get a lot of eyeballs
when I go on so they I think they
this is what they told me because I went
and met with their editorial board
um that you know it was uh that I was
getting more eyeballs than any other
guests wow
on Fox yeah on Fox and um and I think
the same as CNN but CNN won't let me on
the only guy who's let me on CNN was
Michael mcconish and he was a very short
uh interview but
um
he got a lot of trouble for it wow
um so you're running for you're running
right now you're running for president
yeah with the Democratic under the
Democratic party right at the moment
okay and so the is it usual is it normal
that someone is able to run against the
incumbent just I want to make this clear
from audience because some audience I
hear words a lot of times and I don't
know what they mean right so like the
incumbent is the guy who's already in
office right yeah so if a president has
already done one term then he's the
incumbent as he goes up to do the second
term right yeah and he has to run
against someone who's submitted by the
other party well well he he ultimately
has around about the other party you
know is going to nominate somebody to
run against them so the Republicans will
nominate somebody to run again but if
you're a Democrat
if you're popular within your own party
a lot of times you won't have a
challenger from when within your own
party so you'll only have to go to the
prize fight you don't have to
you know fight all the palookas who are
coming after you but and who determines
if they have to fight all the balloons
well it would be you know me I I like I
would run against my father ran against
Linda Johnson when you know Linda John
in 68
Lyndon Johnson was an incumbent
Democratic president and my father
challenged him and and ultimately
um Johnson withdrew
uh and
he pulled out of the way it raised and
then my father won the primaries I mean
he was killed my father was killed on
the night at the last night of the
primaries so June 6th
um he won you know the last primaries
California and South Dakota and a couple
of others and he was killed that night
my uncle Ted Kennedy ran in 1980 against
Jimmy Carter who was a president of his
own party
um so yeah it's not uncommon for for
people to run against uh president their
own party and you know I uh I've had a
long friendship with Biden
I've known President Biden for at least
40 years oh wow and uh and you know he
has a statue a bus my father on the
behind him in the Oval Office any
picture that you haven't Biden there's a
a bust of my father you can call him
now
um and there's five members of my family
who are working in the administration in
the Biden Administration yeah wow at
different you know different ways yeah
yeah and so uh do you think he'll get
the nomination from his party for the
well I think I could beat him in the uh
and yeah that you can see in that middle
one the second one from the right up
there that one there's a there's a
possible life out there behind him wow
that's awesome
that's so cool man that would be cool if
I were my dad
yeah it's wonderful
um do you think that he will get the
yeah so I guess I have two questions
because some of the problems if they
give me a fair fight right bro okay but
before that do you think that they will
he'll get the nomination well I I think
I could get the nomination okay if they
gave me a fair fight I see do you think
that you're currently getting a fair
fight no why well because they're
they're doing you know the Democratic
party is supposed to be neutral they're
not supposed to choose favorites but
they actually endorse them a week after
he declared
and his campaign is being run out of the
democratic party office which seems like
convoluted huh well it's not it's a
conflict and you know because the party
should be separate from the president
even if they're of the same yeah they're
supposed to be even if they're both
democratic yeah the party should be
neutral and say look we're going to be
the referees in this fight it's like
okay it's like if you went to a football
game and the referee in the game was
wearing the same uniform as your the
guys you were playing against right you
say hey hey yeah yeah so that's what
they're doing and what they've done is
they've taken the states
that voted most strongly against by the
last time around and they've said if
anybody visits those if I visit those
States and no vote in that state will
count in the election
so if I go to New Hampshire which I did
any vote that I get in New Hampshire
will not count and if you get to what
for me so if I beat Biden in New
Hampshire and I win all the delegates
those delegates will not be allowed into
the convention but how can they just say
that isn't there like a democratic
process that that overrides that you
would think but actually it the party
makes its own rules and there was a you
know Bernie Sanders they did the same
thing to Bernie Sanders
and he sued them
and said you know you guys were fit
rigged the game against me you fixed it
and the court said yes they did fix it
but actually it's a private club and
they're allowed to fix it it can make up
any rules they want they can do anything
they want so
see this just leans so much more into
like this stuff that like people feel
like they're voting there you go core
can see DNC had the right to rig
primaries against Sanders and that
and that's Debbie Wasserman Schultz who
you know who cared Debbie Wasserman
Schultz for violating the DNC chart
about rigging the Democratic
presidential primaries for Hillary
Clinton against Bernie Sanders and she's
the one who tried to silence me when I
testified before Congress a couple of
weeks ago wow
so anyway it feels like so it feels so
dirty at every turn cold turkey it may
be great on sandwiches but there's a
better way to break your habits
we're not talking about some Voodoo or
seancery or anything like that
we're not talking about getting tickled
by your crazy neighbor until you just
belch up a secret
we're talking about our sponsor fume
that's right they look at the problem in
a different way not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit fume is an
Innovative award-nominated device that
does just that
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural instead of vapor fume
uses flavored air and instead of harmful
chemicals fume uses all natural
delicious flavors you get it instead of
bad fume is good
it's a habit you're free to enjoy and
makes replacing your bad habit easy
indeed stopping is something we all put
off because it's hard but switching to
fume is easy enjoyable and even fun
has served over 100 000 customers
indeed join fume in accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to trifum
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code Theo to
save 10 percent off when you get the
journey pack today that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com trifum and use code Theo
to save an additional 10 off your order
today are you missing the syrup for your
pancakes oh dang or if you just run out
of your favorite coffee creamer
well with doordash grocery delivery you
can get what you want when you need it
that's right
you've trusted doordash to deliver your
restaurant favorites and now you can get
your groceries delivered
right there on the same app
with thousands of grocery stores to
choose from you'll find the best in your
neighborhood and boost your local
economy with each and every order
want even more value you can save on all
your grocery and restaurant favorites
with a zero dollar delivery fee on all
eligible orders with a dash pass
membership you can get it
easy substitutions right in the app and
Best in Class customer support doordash
delivers groceries exactly how you want
them get 50 off your first doordash
order up to a twenty dollar value when
you use code Theo at checkout that's
fifty percent off up to twenty dollar no
minimum subtotal and zero delivery fees
on your first order when you download
the doordash app in the app store and
enter code Theo don't forget that's code
Theo for fifty percent off your first
order with doordash
so it feels so dirty at every turn
yeah I mean it's bad to me it's bad for
the country right now because
so many people think the whole system is
rigged yeah that's what it feels like
man and um if my vote doesn't matter and
we should be I think we should the both
parties should be conducting elections
that are incredibly fair and everybody
looks something that says okay this is a
model the America's the exemplary
democracy for the world should be and
one thing you can say about America is
it has Fair elections and every vote has
counted and you know it's starting to
remind me the articles I would read in
the papers of like Venezuela a lot of
the Central American countries where
they would be
um there would be coups and stuff and
they would be overriding the process
because they thought the elections
weren't fair you know or you know this
will be in the Soviet Union
Communist party they said we're a
democracy but the party would pick the
candidate and that'd be the only guy you
could vote for and that is exactly what
they're doing here they're saying
they're you know they're good they're
saying
the good and the Badness we have a
democracy but there's only one guy and
everybody's got a vote for him but do
they have the right to do that because
he's the incumbent I understand you have
the right to do it within the Democratic
party process okay and then so they you
know they're gonna
you know uh it's weird what's happening
now Theo because
the Press is now turning against
President Biden so it has been
interesting to see some of that huh yeah
it's the first time ever I've seen some
of the headlines that are you know
either bringing like his son's issues
into it or
um discussing impeachment I've never
seen that before you know
yeah and the Washington Post it uh
there's a very famous
journalist called David Ignatius who is
uh linked to the intelligence community
and he kind of speaks if you if you you
know if you if you want to talk about
the Deep State yeah David ignaces the
voice of the deep State and he came out
and said bites got to step down and then
immediately CNN
um published a when uh did a stories
about all Biden's lies and then I think
today either Washington Post or New York
Times oh Maureen Dowd
today about all of uh his lives so that
you see these attacks on Biden I don't
know that were not happening before
right and well you know and you wonder
what what's going on well if he does
step down I hope it's not a far step to
be honest with you because I don't know
if he can handle it you know I think the
sad the saddest thing to me is I feel
like I feel like Mr Biden just isn't
healthy he doesn't seem like mentally
healthy
right to me and I don't know it could be
that they edit Clips to look a certain
way he just seems like he's
he doesn't seem as healthy as he once
was right and so it I feel like to me
it's like a bad example that we this is
what we do with our old people we put
them out it's like this is like a you
know somebody we're just using it just I
don't know it just seems like a bad
example of how to treat other people you
know like this for my father and he were
to me what would seem like ailing like
mentally just kind of either losing his
uh composure that he probably once had
and it could be dementia his cognitive
that's what I'm saying if he were losing
it it would just hurt my feelings if
they kept Wheeling him out there you
know but I don't know maybe that's what
he wants and we just don't hear that
part of it
um
but how so what is your path and to
really get to the presidential
nomination for 2024 is there a path for
you do you feel like
well if President Biden steps out
brother you know the decision kind of
has to be made by October 15th because
there that soon yeah because you'll know
before Halloween yeah the uh October
15th
um you have to start
a qualifying in certain States so that
you you have to declare whether you're a
Democrat or an independent or republican
yeah
and you can't a lot of people think well
you can run as a Democrat and then if
you lose everything then you can just
switch to independent and run on
Independent but you can't do that
because a lot of states have sore loser
laws that make it so that you have to
choose early and you can't go you can't
come in you know once you've chosen
Democrat you can't switch independent
that's fair because every year they let
Odell Beckham Jr join another team right
before the Super Bowl and I feel like
it's the same fair to anybody just I get
that he's good but it doesn't seem that
fair
um so when do you have to so but you've
already chosen that you're a Democrat
right I mean you've been a lifelong
Democrat is there a chance that you
would run as an independent do you look
at that ever like and how do you even
evaluate that yeah I mean I I you know
if they really shut down the process
we're right now you know we're grappling
with the DNC
trying to get them to do the right thing
but if they rig the process so that I
can't possibly win which is how it's
rigged right now
then I would have to look at other
options I would have to look at running
as you know maybe outside of the party
or something I don't know exactly what I
do I'm hoping that they'll open up the
process and let me run
um you know we pulled this week and I if
if I if President Biden steps down
um I I have a pretty clear path to the
nomination my numbers are better than
any other Democrats including the vice
president Kamala Harris
um so and then if he stays in and they
give me a you know a fair fight I think
I can beat him yeah
um so wow so it's kind of it's tough to
figure out kind of you're kind of just
navigating the space huh who's ahead in
the National polls well he beats me
among Democrats in the National polls
but if you could get a third of people
to switch that were Republicans yeah
that's the thing is that those polls
aren't looking at the Republicans who
want to vote for me or The Independents
okay
um if you can't get it run this year
would you run in the next next one no
I'm are you thinking that far ahead okay
no I'm not thinking all about that okay
uh um some people say that you are that
the Republican party like set you up to
take do you ever hear Do you hear about
this yeah I hear that and I'm like a
stalking horse for Trump and all I can
say is you know I don't believe that I'm
just asking you I don't believe it well
you should ask me
I mean you shouldn't do it publicly like
you just did really no no I'm just
kidding okay now you should ask me yeah
yeah but here's the thing here's the
problem with that first of all
if the Democrats make rules that say I
cannot win you know and then they
complain about me running somewhere else
it's like it's like the you know it's
like a guy who murders his parents and
then throws himself on the mercy of the
court because he's an orphan yeah you
know they're they're they're they're
trying to get public sympathy for a
problem that they created I hate when I
see Bananas Foster on the menu
but no I see what you're saying it's
almost like they're playing two cards
that are trying to do two different
things but one of them kind of concedes
that there's some truth in the other one
yeah but and then the other thing is
that I take more votes from president
Trump than I do from President Biden
right so why would that help them yeah
it's not helping them yeah
yeah I thought about that
um
when you look at uh
do you feel like there's
do you feel like that the Democratic
National party has treated you fairly
like they do every other candidate do
they always try to like
how does that usually work I think what
they do you know the DNC has a lot of
donors okay the DNC yeah the Democratic
National Committee you know and the
donors are BlackRock State Street
Vanguard really yeah the big
pharmaceutical company all the people
that I assume Monsanto Etc
they've got two billion dollars in their
bank accounts and it comes from those
donors and they don't those donors do
not want to see me
you know running as the Democratic yeah
yeah and spending their money
environmentalists for sure right and
spending their money then you know to
dismantle their
uh they're very exploited business
models and so Progressive candidates
like me who challenged you know the
corporate control of our country
even like Bernie Sanders Tulsi gambard
and me are are you know told we don't
want you in the party so that's you know
and who do you get an email do you get a
loan it's not a tax time we just watch
what they do with the rules you know how
can they change the rules so that votes
for me in New Hampshire don't count see
it's taking so it's like
you know Dennis kucinich who's running
my campaign who's ran for president
twice himself and Dennis kucinich yeah
he was a
he was the youngest mayor in the country
he was the boy mayor of Cleveland uh you
know they tried the mafia tried to kill
him when he was shot at him and stuff
when he was mayor of Cleveland he's a
very very Progressive
uh and you know man of utter complete
Integrity
but he you know he's been around Paula
he served I think I don't know six or
eight maybe 10 or 12 terms in Congress
he was and he ran for president twice
and
um
he uh he got bullet through his through
his uh I think it was living
um wow
um it's a party
Dennis kucenic yeah anyway he said to me
you know when I was saying uh you know
when we were talking about the
Democratic party he said to me what part
of fu
do you not understand you know they're
not they don't have to write you a
letter and say right you know go jump in
the lake there
they're just saying they're they're
changing the rules so that you know
they're rigging the game against against
the Democratic process does that inspire
you what does that inspire you a little
bit that that's what's going on like you
know I I have the same program you do
yeah just live one day at a time yeah
keep doing the next right thing yeah and
you know trying to maintain kind of my
intercom and not
um and uh you know if God wants me
right to win
I'm gonna I just gotta keep doing the
right thing and I think it's in that
case
that's a great Point man so I I feel
like I mean I go to a meeting every day
I'm in a different city every day and
that's the one thing I always wow
and I I'm been in some good ones
recently anywhere particular that kind
of stood out
I went to one in Maine that was pretty
cool a few months back I got an hour and
a guys was like this and our no I yeah I
went to one the other day where uh
it was a guy and first of all I went to
one in Barbados one time they were
talking no beer for me man they were
talking about it was like a nine-step
meeting and they were talking about how
to take curses off of people
and I went to one in Belfast during the
war there which was really interesting
oh wow yeah but I went to one the other
day and they were um it was uh and I
went to this it was in New Hampshire and
they were they were um
uh and that the people I had been a
couple times and they and the people in
that meeting recognized me they know who
I am most of them
and it's it's a very supportive
atmosphere for me you know I don't know
whether Republicans are Democrats but
anyway it's very not it's a very warm
safe kind of place
and I'm
I heard a guy there was a break they
take those meetings up in New England
they took a five minute cigarette break
halfway through the meeting yeah and uh
it's from like the old old days yeah
and they uh this guy
was sitting like four or five seats
behind me and he he's you know one of
these old people
who talks really loud because he's going
deaf yeah and he's uh you know they
compensate by talking super loud yeah
yeah and he was saying uh
he was saying RFK Jr
and he had three or four of his cronies
around him talking and they were
whispering to him you know that's RFK Jr
and he said he's the antifaxa and I you
know I was just listen I was like you
know I can hear what you're saying
anyway yeah well some senior citizens
are Whispering it's a little a little
high a little high on the whisper and
then he when he did speak at that
meeting and he spoke about
you know how important it was to get
your jab and stuff and um and I could
tell it was directed sort of you know
clearly it was erected with me
but I'm you know I feel like peaceful
and uh afterward I went up and you know
talked to him said hi and and uh and
smile but I I you know it makes me I my
job is
the state sort of peaceful and Serene
and um and not and anything that I've
ever done in my life that is enduring
that is important
um has come out of you know that
spiritual place and anything that I do
that comes from frenetic activity
is uh you know it's just wormwood and
bile I know I I remember reading about
Abraham Lincoln where he you know he was
the rail splitter and everything I had a
bunch of cats too he had cats yeah he's
a big cat owner really I know that he
I know that he loved animals I I did not
know about the cat some man gave him two
hat two some man gave him two cats
William Seward right there oh he was
giving a second gift of two kittens from
Secretary of State he's a real catboy
I've been to his home they you know his
home in Springfield yeah and they one
that one cool thing that's really neat
about Springfield bring it up if you can
Nick they have like the whole
neighborhood they turned into a museum
so you can go to his neighbor's house
you can go down the street it's really
cool yeah like you literally feel like
you're in the past yeah I um so he also
on the same subject of him and animals
he was he killed a turkey when he was
like 12 years old he shot it from his
cabin in Kentucky and gobblers yeah and
he he went out
and he saw it and it's it's final
suffering and he found that he would
never kill an animal again
he was probably the only person in this
generation that when if his wagon was
going down the road it was going to run
over his snake he'd stop and get out and
pick the snake up and move it he was you
know which is ironic because
you know he he had uh he ran a war that
killed 659
000 people but Grant Ulysses Grant who
did a lot of the killing you know hand
to hand
hear the same thing he he never lost
this time the only time that he was ever
seen to lose his temper was when he saw
a man beating a horse hmm some real
animal lovers you know hooker there was
a colonel hooker or general General
hooker that's how they got the term
hookers because he brought ladies in oh
really to spend time with his troops you
know a lot of history of interesting
history I don't know about that but
that's I know about hookers buddy I mean
unfortunately
anyway but I do know that Civil War yeah
they brought in hookers first but
um American Civil War he was popularly
with his men because he didn't crack the
whip
um in terms of discipline it said uh
after a hard day on the battlefield
he would bring in prostitutes but they
eventually a lot of his men got diseases
from unprotected sex and killed a lot of
them anyway moving on I was saying about
Lincoln Lincoln said and he was asked
how do you um
what would you do if you had to cut down
a like a really big oak tree and you had
five hours to do it
he said I'd spend four hours sharpening
the ax you know which is good yeah
because it it's like it's um it's a
metaphor for you know keeping yourself
in kind of a good spiritual space you
know that if it's like it's you're more
efficient you're more effective you
expend less energy yeah yeah man I I
definitely that's been a probably a
struggle for me this year is trying to
do too much getting frenetic and then
acting I'm getting a little better I'm
getting better at it but acting from a
place of like frenetic you know it's
just man sometimes it just gets tough
it's tough you know but every time I
slow it down every time I kind of do my
morning routine well and do my practices
everything's way different
um what was what was one thing that
sobriety we're both sober so what was
one thing that um sobriety kind of
adjusted or changed in your for you in
your life that you didn't expect Maybe
what was something that came out of it
or being a part of it or around it
well it changed everything in my life
because I think before I came in I was
just like a bundle of appetites you know
and that's when you're you're kind of
living
uh according to self-will and you know
it's like whether it's you know drugs or
alcohol or sex or extreme Behavior or
just you know
I was always just filling that empty
hole inside of me with with things
trying to fix that by reaching for
things outside of myself and my mind is
like a formulation Pharmacy I can turn
anything into a drug and
um you know uh
and then
um
and then trying to adjust your compass
so that you're you know you're not
living for self-will but you're trying
to
um do the next right thing and and you
know be of service to others
um and that you know that that is what
you know when I I was a when I I feel
like I was born an addict I feel like I
had just an empty hole inside of me from
when I was a little kid you don't think
so you don't think it was something
really that caused it when you look at
it I don't think so but you know and you
hear in the program all the time like
half the people think
they were born within another to think
that you know trauma you know had
something to do with it but you know I
also I I there's certain races like the
Irish
that oh yeah what we know yeah there's
other ones too they're the most thirsty
yeah I mean they're good they make it
look good I mean I mean we call it the
Irish flu yeah because it it uh
you go into a meeting and you know yeah
in any meeting any place in the country
and half the people in it or you know
Brian and oh yeah a lot of Irish yeah
um was there was there were there was
alcoholism in your family was it popular
in my mother's family it was back to the
Neanderthals wow they were all you know
and of all of my other siblings she was
in the only one that did not get it and
uh wow that's a lot then that's pretty
strong yeah it's just it's it's good to
have a program man I think it adds a lot
I think it's definitely been a Saving
Grace for me uh
for sure just the people I get to meet
like last night a guy texted me a new a
new guy I've been texting in the in the
rooms and we're texting and he he hit me
up yesterday I was like hey you want to
go to a meeting I wasn't going to go you
know so next thing you know I go and
we're like over in Venice and it's 8 P.M
we're sitting on a porch at some guy's
house you know listening to a guy talk
about how he was in a gang and his
brother uh got killed right next to him
you know and uh and now for years he was
using and then finally he started to get
help and got in the program and just but
to sit there and hear a story like that
was that real you know that's part of
the fun of going to the main right I
mean it just puts something real in your
life it's like I left out of there like
sure you know it was very sad but it was
like a real thing it was like I left out
of there with like I don't know it just
people sharing makes you feel more
connected you know you know when you uh
when you got sober did you realize did
you because a lot of I know a lot of
comics feel like you know that the
alcohol and the drugs are part of what
makes them funny did you and that they
have anxiety about getting sober because
they think it might hurt
yeah I think I had some of that for sure
you know I was in and out for a long
time I had three years sober and then I
was in and out and then
finally I just was so spiritually just
empty you know I gotten a decent amount
of popularity and I thought that that
would achieve my happiness or it would
do something for me and it just didn't
do anything it was like literally
getting to a top of a mountain and or
you know a decent ledge on a mountain
and you're like dang I'm still on a
mountain you know that's what it felt
like and so I think that just made me
realize that there was something bigger
going on inside of me that I had to get
some help for
um and then just the gifts of it like
seeing other people get well like seeing
people's lives turn around like just
it's it's cool I can go to a place every
day I can go somewhere and witness a
miracle almost and that's unbelievable
you know people are looking for miracles
and reasons to make them feel you know
and so I think that's one of the reasons
I go to is because there it makes me
feel in there you know like regular life
it was always trying to find something
to make me feel and I could never I
couldn't do it there wasn't anything
that was doing it enough enough but man
I go in there and I see somebody who
their life has changed and man it makes
me feel you know and that's really what
I've always been looking for I've just
been wanting to feel and that's probably
one of the most blessings of it and then
just getting to meet cool I mean like
you know you and I are friends I have so
many most of my friends are sober
yeah you know it's kind of crazy it's
just how it kind of works out and also
some of them needs to be the biggest
derelict so you get to hang out with the
craziest people in the world you know I
mean alcoholics are generally kind of
Desperados yeah oh they're interesting
do you feel like a Desperado in this
campaign I mean one thing that I've that
I thought about was interesting about
you is that nobody was in your pocket
because nobody was getting on board with
you it you know you like yeah it seemed
like there's no choice like there's
nothing that's like this is who we this
is this guy is what he is whether you
he's not working for anybody that's what
it always was like that's the most
admirable thing to me about anything
these days is like I just want somebody
who's not part of the status quo because
the status quo feels very dangerous or
the system feels dangerous you know yeah
does that make sense or not yeah and I
you know it's I don't know I think you
know my campaign the way it came
together it feels I don't know it just
feels like um
uh there's some
you know they're all the people are
involved in it are people who are
you know on some kind of a spiritual
Quest you know and it's it's really
interesting
because they came from all you know
different but you know I there was a
early on in my campaign
wouldn't have any money because most
people who join who started campaign are
their Senators Governors they've been in
politics before right so they have an
email list and they have a huge War
chest they come in with 20 or 30 million
dollars and you're not allowed to raise
any money until you register with the
FEC with federal election commissions
okay you know so you and now I announced
my campaign
and I have no money in the bank so no
you know let's say I get 5 000 calls the
next day I want to help you I got nobody
to answer the phone I don't have a phone
because I'm not allowed to spend money
until I register
and so we were really desperate for
money at the outset and a guy
said
um contacted me and said through a
friend and said you know I wanna I can
get 10 million dollars for you fast and
oh damn nice man uh
I met him in my hotel and I was like one
of those consolidation credit card
things
no it was just a guy you know he was an
attorney who had a lot of clients
in Industries and he said um who would
give me money
but they were industries that I really
didn't want to take money from yeah and
I um and so and he left
and I just didn't it just didn't feel it
felt like it just didn't feel right and
so I called the guy who had brought him
in and I just said I can't do it
and I immediately felt like yeah that
was the right decision yeah you know if
we're supposed to win we'll win but you
know whatever happens
um at the end of this process I'm gonna
have my Integrity intact and that's the
only thing that really matters yeah
um wow that's cool man your wife seems
so proud of you I saw you on tigerbelly
I felt like she seems she seemed so
proud of you it seemed pretty that was
wild that show yeah I thought at first
when I was all there I was like this is
a different world but I think yeah were
you have you been on the show I've been
on the show before yeah and what did you
think of it it's Bonkers in there you
know it's like uh but it's just this
very high energy but yeah he's so he's
such a sweet yeah Bobby's a lovable guy
I love him yeah he is and he's um
what is he like he's had a kind of a
wild life you know he's had an
interesting life and but he's beloved by
people and I think part of his podcast
is just being in his world and what it's
like you know so I thought it was Brave
for you to go but I also thought that it
was cool you know when you got to see
you and your wife and I just felt like
man I could tell your wife to seem real
proud of you maybe she's also just a
good actress but she seems yeah
she seems to love me but you know I have
to keep saying she's an actress how do I
know that's a good point yeah one day
she could just say and scene
um there was recently there was like you
guys had a uh you guys had an issue with
the security right that that happened
this is a few days ago maybe where they
had a guy who was a like it looked like
he was uh here we go arm man arrested at
RFK Junior campaign event in Los Angeles
was this guy armed and supportive of you
or was he armed and it seemed like he
was against you or was there did you
have any take on this
he was he showed up and he asked um
yeah he was wearing a U.S Marshal badge
you can see it in some of the he was
wearing a lanyard you can see the
lanyard around his neck there and at the
end and that is a badge and identified
him as a U.S Marshal
and then he hit a federal ID on his belt
okay you can see there yeah right he has
some other kind of badge on his belt and
you see the badge around his neck
and um
and that was determined to be fake and
somebody from my Gavin Decker Associates
was just was doing is doing my security
they want you know the White House will
not give me sacred service protection so
I you know I've I've retained this this
group that's the premier
Security Group in the country and they
um and one of their guys looked at that
badge and said that's too shiny it's not
it's not a real badge and so then they
he why he called somebody else who's
armed
and the two of them cornered him and
then they called the police and they
kept them in the corner they didn't want
to grab them because they didn't want to
start a shootout
and they could see that he had shoulder
holsters on eBay and so then the police
came and arrested me he was asking for
me
oh he was looking for me and he uh he
had two shoulder holsters that were
fully loaded uh pistols and then he had
you can see that badge on his hip yeah
he's badged up huh yeah and then he uh
and he had he was also had a backpack
that had another weapon in it
another guy like a sword he also had
knives on him and he had a lot of extra
um magazines filled with ammunition so
he said afterwards apparently his
brother said oh he heard there was a job
opening for security but you don't go to
a job opening for security
guns and knives and two three pistols
his brother who brought him there also
was like you know like an Armory right
they had all car filled with with
weapons wow I have no idea I don't know
what he was looking for but I'll tell
you what the thing that you should do is
go on his YouTube I mean his uh Tick
Tock yeah he is a tick tock it's like
that he just opened so he only has one
really
yeah
nickel find it it is uh
at the end of that thing he says
something to the effect of
I'm going out to do a job right now and
if I don't come back you know it's I if
I don't come back report to your
commander
Donald J Trump
your commander a chief so it's a very
kind of okay you want to watch this it's
about a minute yeah it's worth watching
let's watch it you gotta turn the sound
up
oh big homie Zorro over here I
think this is his brother talking to him
more like God's gangster I hear
you're the man with the plan what's the
word I got it all
actually there's too much to tell you
right now
so I want you guys to go over to rumble
check out icons 2020
Sarge I will be speaking with him
and Alex Collier
you're not retiring homie you didn't
ask me dog
I need you support okay assistant's not
doing well huh no yeah
and this could also be an advertising
for rumble first name
[Laughter]
the last
like I don't know 10 seconds here we go
if I don't make it back
call the president
your commander-in-chief Donald J Trump
and where's he going I didn't see a door
over there when it was a wide shot so
that's the weird part if you just
walking just over here like find some
tool chests
wow I mean look dude just I don't know
yeah you don't have y'all don't have the
best track record with like
um you know you mean the family yeah I
don't want to say that but yeah I mean
and yeah I shouldn't have said it like
that but you know it's like is it more
scary but you can't live in fear what
are you gonna do I'm not gonna live in
Fair yeah I I know yeah
it is what it is and
um you know but but the the White House
should definitely be giving me secret
service or can you save your receipts
and if you get in there can you get
reimbursed or not what no oh yeah oh so
and I think that's what they're up to
that they want to you know bleed me
white essentially you know from money
perspective but I'm
a I'm the first candidate in history
that has requested Secret Service
protection they haven't given to but do
they give it to you this early because
here's what because the the Press has
been dishonest about this
you're entitled to it they have to give
it to you 120 days out from the before
the the general election if what what
circumstances to all candidates 120 days
out okay well you have to have a certain
polling number but I've I've surpassed
all the thresholds by far okay
so
um but like my Uncle Teddy was given a
secret service protection 551 days out
but he was also Apollo he was like a
lifelong politician well he was a he was
a politician but he wasn't even running
for president he
he was talking about running for
president against a president his own
party like me it's not harder but Carter
said
you better protect him right away right
and even though he hadn't officially
declared the Secret Service protection
Obama got it 450 days out John McCain
got it
four or five hundred days out I'm I
think I'm like 300 days out now
Jesse Jackson got it Shirley Chisholm
you go down there's probably 30 of them
who've all gotten it long before the 120
days okay
and I get you know I mean we gave them a
68 page
um yeah I'm reading about that yeah and
why you should have it yeah
because I get death threats all the time
and I you know I had a mentally ill
person
I break into my house a month ago and
and make it to the second floor no are
you at your house yeah so oh my God you
know I mean so I I they should you would
think that the president would uh yeah
you don't if you know Biden can't you
just like ask him well we're not I'm
talking terms at the moment okay
damn that's a bummer yeah because you
think you'd be able to hit him up and be
like Joey you know
trade you an ice cream for a couple of
front door goons you know you know what
I'm saying a couple Sharpshooters dude I
bet you trade you sent him a box of mint
chocolate chip but he'll get whatever
you want you think yeah it could be I
mean you know I think every man loves to
have a dessert
um do you think that Donald Trump will
will legally be allowed to run in the
election
yeah I don't think they can I'm from
running even if he was in jail yeah
he's still entitled to run because
there's only you know the the
Constitution uh
the Constitution says there's only three
things that you got to do to be you have
to be a citizen you have to be born in
here and you have to be over 35 years of
my age okay
and that's it you can be a president
there's like there's no way to block
somebody because they got convicted uh
you know it's in the Constitution what
the criteria is for being president yeah
it's funny because I feel like some
people like Trump because they he just
wasn't a politician you know he could
have been anybody he could have been a
fraggle he could have been a a mime I
think some people just want anything
that's not they just something has to
change they feel like at the very least
I'll vote for something that's not a
politician I just feel like people start
to feel like this the overall system is
so corrupt you know
um and I think that's something that's
been kind of harrowing just to voters
overall
um
you know people are
people are suffering in this country now
yeah we're not you know like I said
before when you know with housing
our kids are not going to get you know
the American promise the American dream
was at this promise that if you worked
hard you believe other rules you could
afford a house you could have a summer
vacation you could take care of your
family
and you could put money aside from
retirement with one job yeah and there
you know my kids that you know I have
seven kids you know six of them are in
that 20 30 range and not none of them
and none of their friends are looking
for a house because it's so Out Of Reach
and I'm you know you have all generation
of kids who now are struggling with with
college accidents they what they they
recall it was seven times what I paid
they're never going to pay off that
college debt and they're never going to
own a home for most of these kids and
it's like like you know the American
dream is gone right and so then if you
don't have an American dream then what
do you have you know that's I think
that's the reason it starts to get sad
that's one of the reasons that people
are so angry at both Republicans and
Democrats because there's a level of
disintegration in this country and
deterioration I mean I
you know I do I end up talking to a lot
of people because of my job you know I I
represent a thousand families in
Columbiana County Ohio for the Norfolk
Southern spill oh yeah um and you know
all of these environmental cases I end
up talking to people at every level of
society and I see the desperation that
people are living in it's like
you know elderly people now are
splitting their prescription or their
drug prescriptions cutting pills into to
make them
stretch out the week so they can buy
food there's these young couples who
have a crying baby you have to wonder
whether the baby is fifty dollars sick
or 100 sick or
fifteen hundred dollars sick before they
bring them to a hospital yeah there's
people you know your age and my kids age
who um who are choosing between gasoline
and food
and uh you know there it's a 57 of
people in this country cannot put their
hands on a thousand dollars if they have
an emergency
for somebody like that if the engine
light goes on in the car it's the
apocalypse yeah because they they know
they can't afford that mechanic
they know okay now I can't get to work
I'm going to lose my job then I'm gonna
lose my house and then I'm going to be
like all those people in San Francisco
who are just regular you know Joes yeah
and they should not they weren't drug
addicts they weren't mentally ill they
just had a string of bad luck there the
engine light went on their car and they
couldn't find the mechanic that's what I
feel like I feel like the engine lights
on in this country yeah that's what I
feel like well you know when you're you
know when you're driving around with
your engine on empty oh yeah yeah and
you yeah right and you can't think of
anything else because you're thinking
how am I going to be able to get that
gas tank and it literally makes you
stupid it makes you you lose IQ because
that's all you can think about now
put two kids in the back of your car you
know one toddler in a baby seat and
another kid and you're now magnifying
that anxiety and now you're driving
through a bad neighborhood and you're
starting to think of all of the bad
things that well that's what it's like
living paycheck to paycheck and that's
what Americans are doing and uh
it's like most Americans wake up every
day and with that sense of impending to
them and they're it's like they're
driving around empty they don't know
what's going to happen and they're
desperate and they and nobody is
listening to them the politicians aren't
listening to the Republican or the
Democrats
and Donald Trump comes along and says
I'm going to break things and uh and
they love him and I get it you know and
the Democrats can't understand why are
all these people liking Donald Trump
that's the reason yeah because you're
not listening to him yeah I think and
people want anything I'd have voted for
I'd vote for a literally a puppet I'd
vote for Grover I'd vote for anything
that wasn't Apollo you know that wasn't
a career politician because I'm just so
over it and you see these shows like
painkiller and like um yeah that one on
Hulu too the one that I can't remember
yeah what was it called the one about
the sacklers yeah yeah
if that show didn't ruin your faith in
taking care of people in this country
it's unfucking real man I hate to use
that language but it made me so mad bro
yeah it just made me so mad how
compromised we are how it feels you know
um because if we're not even out here
caring about each other then what are we
even doing you know that's what it
starts to feel like it's like if we're
not out here trying to do something like
then what are we we're just then what
you know I'm just out here to have a
nice car it's just I don't know man yeah
it's it's about is it about
we're just here to make a big pile for
ourselves and whoever dies with the most
stuff wins yeah but we've proven that
there's no value in it it's like it's
been proven over and over again that
there's no value in it you know
um when you uh
when you come across people like that
right on your campaign Trail and you
like what do you offer them what type of
Hope do you offer them well you know I
think that's why I have because
I mean I have specific things that I'm
going to do to make well I mean like
with housing one of the things I'm gonna
do
is I'm going to make a three percent
mortgage available to every American for
a single family home
oh if you right now you know you're
gonna pay seven or eight or nine percent
I'm going to cut that down so your
mortgage for the average home 215 or 400
000 a thousand dollars a month
which people can afford and it's going
to allow you to compete and your kids to
compete with BlackRock
I'm going to change the tax code to make
it more difficult for them to you know
to buy up all the single family homes
which is not good for democracy not good
for our country
you know if you have a rich uncle
you can get a uh who will Coast on your
mortgage you can get a much cheaper
mortgage rate because the bank is
looking at his credit rating you know
his perfect credit rating rather than
your nepotism kind of oh you know
they're and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to give everybody a rich Uncle
which is Uncle Sam I'm gonna get uh the
U.S government to Coast on your mortgage
now if you default
and the government owns your house oh no
foul no loss
but it's going to allow you to stay in
that house and you know I'm going to
give the first half Mill 500 000 to
teachers because we need to start
supporting the teachers in this country
but to make them available to all
Americans who want a single family home
because we need widespread homeownership
Thomas Jefferson said American democracy
can only survive if they're if it's
based on
on tens of thousands of independent
freeholds owned by individual Americans
and you know not big corporations the
aristocratic the feudal model
where the billionaires on the Landscapes
and we all are you know we we're no
longer Citizens We're now you know we're
now subjects or not you know we're serfs
on our in our own country yeah that's
what it feels like it feels like we're
subjects and the Lords won't even tell
us who they are yeah exactly that's the
sickest part at least show your
face you know at least let me know who's
you know it's like that's what it feels
like a lot of times
um I know you went and visited the
Border we had a border patrol security
uh we had a gentleman on here who was
the head of the border patrol oh Chris
clam no this guy he had retired huh Roy
Villarreal okay he came on here this is
two years ago and he was talking about
one of the biggest issues that he was
noticing at the border this was in
Arizona that was his jurisdiction was
that
um they were people were getting the the
the the legislative branches weren't
working well so like they would arrest
people but they weren't Prosecuting them
so they would get just the same people
back over and over again so it seemed
like such a goose chase
um
100 times worse now wow is now that
people are just I mean I was there
between two and four a.m in the morning
I watched 300 people just walk across
and then the border patrol brings them
to the airport and um you know they
probably they fingerprint them but
they're criminal then they go into a
different you know line but the rest of
them are brought to the Yuma Airport
given a um uh I took it to any place
they want to go on the United States and
then we pay for it if they don't have
the money for it and you know they've
110 000 have landed in New York and this
is a humanitarian crisis I I talked to
the people who are coming over
they've been exploited extorted beaten
what's what's happened is the the whole
thing's run by the Mexican drug cartel
we saw the buses the AF white buses the
cartelons
55 people have passed they picked them
up in Mexicali and they bring them to
the border and they let them out the
people who come out are from every
country they're not you know they're
from all over and they have to pay the
cartel from Asia right they have to pay
the cartels to get through their land 50
well
right but they pay them usually up front
ten to fifteen thousand dollars to get
them across the United States and the
cartels are advertising all over the
world and they're advertising on YouTube
they're telling you exactly what's going
to happen to you
they come across and then what happens
is they're given by the border patrol
the Border there's nine border patrol
committed suicide because what they're
being asked to do is not their job
they're just
escorting people seven million people
have come across illegally in three
years and
legal immigration during that period was
3.1 million so the cartels are literally
controlling our immigration policy and
uh
we have a video that I made you know an
18-minute video that shows what happened
but but you were only down there for
what how long were you down there for I
was there for three days okay and then
um you know and then we've been feeling
you know we made the film we you know
I've been writing a lot about it and
researching it and it can totally be be
uh shut down overnight they're not and
what happens is people think what well
there there's all those people
but I just wonder is that a long enough
like time to go see it like three days
is that a realistic I had three intense
days first of all the first night
watching all these people come and then
spending the next days with local law
enforcement local sheriff's department
the ice
a border patrol or the local medical
systems the doctors and doing you know
yeah interviews no it's good to talk
with those people that's why we wanted
the guy because we kept hearing the
Border but it gets it gets like becomes
like this political like Red Rover that
that that different parties use and you
never know what's going on that's why we
wanted a border patrol agent in so we
could really see what happens there's a
guy called Chris clam who was the head
of the Border Patrol and Yuma
and he's fantastic and he's giving us
advice but you know what happens is if a
lot of the Democrats think oh we're
being kind to these people by letting
them in but we're not in fact
what happens is they're given a court
date for seven years in the future to go
to the Asylum court so they have seven
years in this country where there they
have no legal
status
so they're not allowed to work so they
um they they'll work for five or six you
know you have unscrupulous employers
yeah five or six bucks an hour and then
you know they're they're employed on
construction sites in New York
the employee of the construction company
that's employing them is competing for
bids against a union labor company
because he's paying six bucks an hour
right so but just but just as guilty as
the as the people who are undermining
the system right as they are of
undermining the system people can have
their own like uh social beliefs about
it but there is guilt of undermining
what the system is that's in place but
those the people that pay them to work
are also guilty right if they're yeah I
mean when I you know what here's what I
would do
and first of all you need you need to
hire a thousand Asylum judges and you
need to adjudicate before people come in
once they come in they're entitled to
stay here they get a court date put them
right on the border like judge you
exactly and they adjudicate right there
and um and and then it will shut down
the border and but most of the people 99
of the people we interviewed didn't even
have an asylum claim they just said I'm
here to work I want a job right and so
they you know they are not entire they
have to come through the regular line
like everybody else legally yeah that's
what's fair is just doing it legally
because you can't keep if you don't have
Accounting in inventory of your business
then you're bound to go yeah you know
I'll tell you how you shut it down
overnight and this is what I'm going to
do the day I get into office
I'm going to wave pass Point fees for
all any American who can't afford it now
what that means is if you can get a
passport card I don't know if you've
seen it looks like a license right it's
a federal ID with your picture on it
and the problem is it costs 65 and
there's some paperwork attached that
makes it difficult for very poor people
to get them
and so there's a lot of people in our
country who are poor particularly in
cities who don't drive cars they don't
have a driver's license they have no
government issued ID now if you don't
have a government issued ID
you're a second class citizen you cannot
open a bank account which means you're
using you know the the uh paycheck uh
you know companies that take 10 of your
Social Security check to cash your check
you can't get on an airplane you can't
stay at a hotel you can't visit your
kids at school and
um so what I'm going to do there's 33
000 post office in this country I'm
going to make it very easy for any
American citizen who can't afford it to
go down to the local post office and get
a passport ID
once they do that you now tell employers
you cannot hire somebody unless they
have that passport right day I will shut
down the Border overnight because
nobody's going to come through if they
know they cannot get a job because now
you're probably now you can prosecute
employers right now what they do the
employer construction firm in New York
they they're just they don't care if
you're legal or illegal
they just want somebody who's cheapest
possible and that they can check the box
so they asked for social security card
the Social Security card has no picture
on it they're easily fabricated and
they're handed you know passed down from
person to person oh yeah those things
are nuts right and so you can't put the
employer in jail
because he says hey I I got a social
security card but now you're telling the
employer the employer is illegal for the
employer to do it right and now you're
saying you gotta have a passport card
where you're going to jail okay that at
that point all illegal employment dries
up overnight nobody is going to employ
somebody with the risk of going to
prison
but and one other thing it'll do is that
um it will solve a lot of the anxieties
that people have Republicans
particularly about voting
because they say oh you know these
people are coming in and they're voting
people are voting without ID and they're
double voting they're committing voting
for well now everybody has an idea and
you can't have any of that kind of
voting fraud
and and the Democrats supported I mean
the Democrats will support it although
Biden won't sign this bill but um but
you know the big civil rights leaders
like Andy young Al Sharpton are all
behind this ID this idea so we can solve
all these problems and the anxieties in
the debate about the voting system and
whether you need ID or not right now
Democrats oppose ID laws and the reason
they what they opposite is they say if
you get if you force people to show an
ID you're disenfranchising a lot of
students who don't have driver's license
you're disenfranchising poor people who
live in the city who don't have driver's
license
and there's other people in the country
elderly people a lot of their license
have left so they don't have ID and you
disenfranchise all of those those are
all Democrats so the Democrats say we
shouldn't ID laws now we've got civil
rights leaders who's saying yeah let's
have IDs to vote but let's give
everybody an ID so everybody can get one
right then nobody has an excuse and
nobody has an excuse yeah
what do you say to so some people would
say that that it that takes away some of
the old like adage and the old like uh
romantic idea of like
um you can come to America and you can
make it here does that does that do that
by making the Border because what are
you doing making the Border more
organized you're not saying there's no
country in the world that
has an insecure border yeah
we have to be able to control
we should let a lot of people in Legally
make it much easier to get citizenship
um and make sure that there's plenty of
people to you know to uh for employers
Etc
so that we can keep our country humming
yeah right and but we should be able to
select who comes through not have the
Mexican drug cartels select I agree it's
a good point no it's I mean it's
disheartening it's very scary to think
that anybody can just come in you know I
mean I know that we're all here and
we're blessed to be here I just think it
needs to be organized
um remember when Reagan had that plan
that couldn't you sponsor people that
were coming in well you still can you
know that people that'd be awesome bro
well but you still can do that I mean
legally 3.1 million people are coming
across and a lot of them are coming
across unvisas that require them to have
a sponsor because they're employment
visas
an employer says we need this guy we
need to bring him from Uzbekistan let's
bring him one hit or I'll sponsor Hector
to sponsor your family member submit a
U.S citizen United States citizenship
and Immigration Services form 130 each
person you sponsor needs a separate form
130. huh let me ask you this we should
sponsor one is a podcast
how long has your family been in this
country let me see my father came over
in
1922. from where from Nicaragua and my
mother I don't know when she came
probably probably she's probably been
here for like 100 200 years
so and what it what like ethnic group
issues let me see polish Italian and
Nicaraguan that's what I am
and Nicaraguan is that Hispanic or is it
Indian or um actually it's a good
question it's uh it's a little bit of
both I think it's part Aztec maybe I
gotta check and see the mosquito Indians
are down there are they oh yeah dude
that's probably me then
um I gotta see my but I remember my
father's birth certificate
um but have you ever done like 23 in May
or anything like that yeah I've done it
I don't know what they said they email
me so much they're like guess who's
allergic to milk in your area they're
always sending like weird emails now you
know yeah I know I and I don't trust
them really yes
we got all my stuff yeah guess who it's
guess who hates cinnamon rolls on your
street you know they're like what what
does this matter is it a cousin or not I
went hiking this morning with Tulsi
gabbard you went hiking with her yeah
and I was asking her about her you know
her ethnic background and she said she
did 23. she actually did uh there's a TV
show with a
um they they investigate your background
oh yeah they do it with celebrities I
thought I think yeah Barrymore was on it
yeah and she did that oh that's good
they said
um that she had the most ethnically
diverse background that they'd ever run
into wow she is she is uh art Samoan so
she's Polynesian yeah I like that yeah
that's fantastic and she uh but then
she's got everything else you know she's
got the whole like every country in
Europe I wish I could be Samoa and I
wish I could be Mexican some sometimes
um maybe next life you know
um what will keep you say you get in
office Bobby right like what keeps you
right a guy that is trying to do it his
way how do you get
um sabotaged how do guys get sabotaged
once they get into office like how do
people get con like their values and
their goals and stuff get commandeered
and stuff well a lot of people you know
that happens to them but um I you know
I've been fighting corporations for 40
years yeah and I've been suing these
agencies so probably 20 I've sued almost
every one of these agencies dot yeah
USDA Department of Agriculture EPA NIH
FDA to her yeah so I you know I feel
like I know better than anybody else
about how to unravel the corporate
capture and you know I'm not interested
in anything they got nothing they can
offer me yeah you know the only thing
I'm concerned with is good government
and
making sure that our kids you know love
America the way that I love and have
hope for their future and that's you
know they're I mean literally I can't
think of anything
than anybody could give me to buy me off
there's nothing I want you know I have
everything that I want and I just
um you know I want to I want to do the
right thing and I you know I think
there's other people I think Tulsi is
the same way I don't think she has any
personal ambition
um I think she just you know she loves
our country and um I think there's other
politicians out there too who can't be
bought but most of them can
do you stay with them and in fact the
entire political process has been bought
of running to office is a training
school for teaching you how to get
bought yeah you know so
it's what it seems like it's like where
the Warriors who want to die
like for something that means something
yeah you know I I'm with you I don't
know I mean I guess I don't know we all
get it's all it's it's hard it's we live
in a place where that's what we've built
it's part of that you that things can be
compromised uh the last question I have
is um where do um
if you how do you know if you are going
to stay running with the Democratic
party if you have to make another Choice
well I have to make that choice by
October 15th okay
so I'm just gonna see what they do if
they open up the process they'll all
stay in and then you know and then I
have to see what I have to see if they
don't close it then I don't know exactly
what I'll do
I'm proud of you man I'm just excited to
know you've always been uh you've always
just been a nice guy man you've always
been
um someone I can rely on and so I just
appreciate uh you just being willing to
come back on and spend time with us and
help us learn about
um the election process and stuff I
think even if listening you helps us you
know a lot of people like me just learn
who aren't as up to you know skew on
politics and
um yeah man certainly uh happy to get to
spend time with you and congratulations
man I'm proud of you yo thanks for
having me back yeah
it's always a pleasure being with you
yeah thanks Bobby I'll talk to you soon
[Music]
Cornerstone
I reach that ground I'll share this
piece of my life
[Music]
gonna take